[Music]
it's been over a year in the making but
the overwatch League is finally here
Blizzard's premier eSports circuit for
the game it'll feature over a hundred
players from around the world with 12
cities playing host to them
Boston Dallas Florida that's not a city
Houston London Los Angeles Los Angeles
again New York Philadelphia San
Francisco Seoul and Shanghai who the
players will compete in a six-month long
regular season ending with a 16 playoff
and a grand final to determine the big
winners there will even be a weekend for
all-star activities where your favorite
players will join in to compete in
unexpected challenges as Blizzard calls
them and along the way there will be
both thrilling victories and crushing
defeats so look out for but as they say
winning isn't everything as there are
many things that will come to define the
league's first year from underdog
stories to new metas here are four
things to look out for during the first
season of the overwatch League overwatch
is ever evolving meta has seen players
experiment with a bunch of different
team comps from World of Tanks to dive
coms to the current mercy based team
structure some metas have in the past
dominate an entire season of competitive
play but there's a chance that the
current strategies won't fare as well in
the overwatch League as Blizzard
continues to release new heroes and make
tweaks to existing ones teams are bound
to come up with brand new ways to win
we've already seen London's team the
Spitfire employ some unconventional
tactics to secure victories in the
preseason and with the stakes raised
even further it's only a matter of time
until the rest of the league steps out
of their comfort zone and starts
experimenting and when they do it'll be
an exciting season to watch for sure
it's no secret no matter of the game
South Korea has had much of the eSports
landscape locked down for years and the
overwatch League is no different out of
the league's 113 current players nearly
40% of them or two out of every five
players are Korean and three teams the
New York Excelsior London Spitfire and
Seoul dynasty have rosters comprised
entirely of players from the country
surprising no not in the slightest
but the overwatch leagues worldwide
representation and city based teams make
it more than just about national pride
as in any sport we'll be cheering our
hometown teams on no matter where the
players might hail from just as Blizzard
refined the hero shooter formula it
could do the same for eSports as well
it's highlighted the most of
recognizable parts city based teams
colors and mascots full schedules with a
postseason and all-star game making it
much more digestible for the casual
viewer to jump right in eSports has long
been a tenant of online streaming
services like twitch but that's slowly
been making its way into the mainstream
by way of television broadcasts while it
doesn't quite appear as if Blizzard is
moving away from twitch as its sole
broadcast partner maybe overwatch
doesn't need to be on TV we've already
started seeing matches of the preseason
being shown on projectors at some fine
drinking establishments sure they made
cater towards the gaming public but
what's the stop any old bar from
broadcasting the overwatch League grand
finals for everyone to watch
as part of the inaugural season of the
overwatch League Blizzard is offering
some hefty rewards for the winning team
and I'm not talking about a good old pat
on the back I'm talking about a shiny
seven-figure bonus for the winning team
in addition to the sizeable 50k minimum
salary that all players make you're in
the regular season with the total prize
pool set at 3.5 million dollars
Blizzard looks to be following through
with his promise of a sustainable
eSports future for its players which is
a great thing for both blossoming
newcomers and veterans alike now the
current season is broken up into four
stages and the top three teams in each
stage will also compete in separate
title matches for a cash bonus which
will net the winners in additional
$100,000 and the title of stage winner
but that's just pittance compared to
what they could walk home with at the
end of the season come July when the
first overwatch League champions are
finally crowned they will walk away with
a cool million dollars and if luck is on
our side a giant novelty check man I
love those things so those are four
things that you should definitely look
out for during the first season of the
overwatch League but certainly not the
only things no doubt we'll have some
huge upsets insane plays of the game and
probably a little bit of drama a lot
will unfold in these next six months so
make sure you visit GameSpot calm as
we'll have plenty more coverage of the
overwatch league as it happens my name
is Joey and thanks for watching